então boa tarde a todos
começava por dizer que você não sabe que
isso é porque não é mãe e é talvez por
causa dos meus filhos que têm vindo a
pensar ou têm vindo a descobrir se este
mundo dos das partilhas do chefe do
facebook do instagram diz tudo isto são
redes sociais que efetivamente não
sancionadas sociais
então aqui o desafio que hoje aqui vos
10 é como ou esta reflexão talvez
reuniões e muito na linha 10 de 13
intervenções anteriores
é como as redes que vocês vivam na
escola com os quais vocês vivem podem
ser realmente sociais
o meu mundo como no caso do que se é
diferente do mundo no quadro vivo
no entanto podem deixar em vencer nós
podem ignorar porque hoje o mundo
realidade do mundo têm menos uma
dimensão não existe distância
eu tinha um filho durante um ano e já
estava conosco camisa
nunca deixamos 17 e no entanto quando o
país só falava com os meus pais
domingo o mundo o mundo hoje nosso mundo
no qual eu me incluo claro das redes e
das redes sociais têm de ser olhados
como algo mais do que partilhar imagens
de jovens em pós de estúpidas
o de partilhar stafford pode querer
partilhar com os outros e que o que eu
penso que sou uma forma como eu mas vai
então tudo isso que temos que falar o
que falar tudo isso tem que temos que
acreditar é que nós fizemos quarto
integrante do mundo onde as reduz podem
ser mais do que projetará na imagem que
pensamos que ter no mundo as redes podem
adquirir um poder uma força incrível que
pode mudar esse mundo
o mundo hoje é assim daqui a cinco anos
daqui dois anos vai ser diferente e
forma como tudo isto mexe com tudo isto
muda implica que nós nunca esquecemos
que somos homens e que temos é um mundo
onde é participação e responsabilidade
então nas causas naquilo que como regra
como opção de vida eu sou voluntária por
opção há 25 anos é exclusivo e dediquei
minha vida é fazer com que sua lógica de
existência na loja onde é palavra cuco e
que pensa em portugal em português como
uma de duas palavras colaboração e
competição podem gerar mais valor
vamos fazer dois exemplos como as redes
podem criar muito valor
a campanha do banco alimentar na
internet há 25 anos que hoje são 21 em
portugal
são 264 na europa em 23 países
há 25 anos
que ajudem nesta sala que não conhece as
vantagens do banco alimentar fisicamente
pessoas pessoas que estão à porta do
supermercado e que convidam outras
pessoas é que sejam solidários com quem
tá imagens cidades da sua região
estamos a falar de pessoas pessoas redes
de suas professoras pessoas que pedem
comida pra dar de comer a quem precisa
suas do seu tempo entre pilar pessoas
constituída que o que é uma rede física
uma real e pensarmos por que não
transportarem na internet porque não é
votar o modelo do banco alimentar de
pessoas para pessoas
é algo que é uma realidade virtual mas
que hoje em dia ao que não se pode
pensar que não existe então criamos a
campanha do banco alimentar na internet
e que seja algo simples rápido e que
tivesse relação com as redes sociais
porque queremos fazer realmente social
onde esta campanha do banco alimentar na
internet é muito mais do que o portal é
uma causa uma causa onde todos tinham
juntado na primeira campanha online do
banco alimentar
tivemos entradas 91 países foram 105 mil
euros isto é muito alimento que eu quero
físico onde os voluntários continuam a
convidar todos os portes físicos
materiais para a nossa vida
passámos pode digitar o que permitiu
passar fronteiras da europa sociais
segundo exemplo onde há pessoas que
querem voluntários que queiram dar o seu
tempo que apenas se inscreva no sítio na
internet mas onde desafia as
instituições precisam de voluntários vão
procurar online porque nós vivemos numa
altura em que tudo rápido rápido então
voz
que dificilmente realidades diferentes
setores diversos podem acompanhar esse
ritmo o setor onde eu trabalho no setor
social é um setor lento é lento porque
todos os dias lida com pessoas que
precisam dessa lentidão é um setor que
tem que ser humano e viver ao ritmo do
homem por quem assiste pessoas porque
assisti três pacientes porque existe
idosos porque existe crianças foram
abandonadas pelos seus pais porque
existe pessoas que perderam a esperança
que perder o emprego então essa lentidão
que é o mané
tem de existir no entanto não significa
que nós posso utilizar as ferramentas
todas ao dispor para enviar pessoas para
mobilizar pessoas competências talentos
que queiram partilhar net então esta
bolsa do voluntariado com digo hoje ao
site português de voluntariado vive
porque instituições inscrevem criou uma
oportunidade de voluntariado onde as
pessoas podem dar o seu tempo a sua vaga
era a sua casa ou numa em uma causa é
quase idêntico
isso significa que nós estamos a fazer
com que o terceiro setor
o setor social possa usar uma ferramenta
mantendo a sua humanidade
então o que fizemos foi taliqua listei
este desafio que eu desejo é que se o
nosso usar as redes sociais fazendo uma
partilha com os nossos amigos que são
nossos amigos e que nos seguem sem
perder de vista a parte humana que
existe em cada um de nós mas a parte
humana que pode existir nestas redes
sociais
aquilo que nós estamos a fazer são redes
que ganham mais força porque permitem
uma partida
o que é mais humana onde o ser e onde é
a disponibilidade para o outro pode
ganhar de facto mais um sentido
é isso que temos feito é este o apelo
que os 10
é isso que eu queria partilhar convosco
é que em cada momento da nossa vida
porque sabem que hoje o mundo é de uma
maneira mas que amanhã este mundo vai
ser necessariamente diferente porque a
ok não podemos parar que a evolução
desta tecnologia que é uma resolução
maior do que a eletricidade equipe
sempre qual é marca que querem deixar e
como a parte humana pode ser
transportada por estas redes tornando as
realmente sociais porque podem de facto
ajudar a mudar a vida das pessoas que
nunca perderam a sua componente humana
muito obrigada